[Music]
13 one in eight women will be diagnosed
with breast cancer in their lifetime
that's why it is so important to do a
monthly self-exam and especially get
your annual mammogram in today's buddy
check report the American Cancer Society
wants to help patients receive the
treatment they need and getting to an
appointment shouldn't be an obstacle our
local chapter talked with Denise Valdez
about free Transportation program it
offers
we have a road to recovery program so
for people going through Cancer Care
they can call our 1-800 number or go on
our live chat if they need a ride to
treatments
um and it is free to the patient we have
a great volunteer base that helps pick
them up and get them to appointments all
right you heard that right a vetted
volunteer will pick you up and take you
to your appointment for free
well look at that you look carefully you
might recognize the driver on the left
there are former Running Rebels coach
long Kruger you can find all of our
buddy check reports at 8newsnow.com